I would sit down with the engineers,
the developers of the software and say,
explain this to me,
so that I completely understood it
and only then could I write about it.
Because, I mean,
if you've ever tried to explain something
you don't understand,
it doesn't work, right?
But if you understand it, you can take
what is complex and make it simple.
Minette Norman,
welcome to 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you for joining me.
How are you?
I'm good.
Thanks for having me
and for inviting me
Of course.
Thank you.
Where are you calling from right now?
I'm in the San Francisco Bay Area.
I live in Marin County,
just north of San Francisco.
Wonderful.
It's a beautiful, beautiful area.
I really enjoyed
going hiking there before covid
and hopefully after covid as well.
More than 30 years of experience
in the tech and software industry,
but it all starts with nothing else
but a major in drama and French.
How does that happen?
Exactly.
I'm not quite sure.
But I'll tell you
the brief story of how it all went down.
So, I got out of university
with a degree in drama and French
and realized that being an actor,
which I aspired to be,
is a really hard work.
And I hated going to auditions.
And I realized that wasn't for me.
So, I had to get a job.
My first job out a school
was being a French teacher.
But soon after that,
I got a job at the
French Trade Commission
in New York City where I was living,
when they introduced computers
for the first time.
And it turned out,
this is going way, way back,
this dates me more than twice your age,
I think Michael,
but this was like the original PCs,
the IBM PC is back in the 80s,
and it turned out I was a quick study.
And I learned how to use them.
I figured out
how to use them pretty well.
But what I was really good at
was explaining how to use them
to the people who didn't understand
and who were kind of scared
and intimidated by them.
And so, that led me,
that was sort of the crucial step
in my career that led me
to the tech industry.
I decided to leave New York
back in the late 80s
and moved to California,
where I'd grown up, in the Bay Area.
And I decided,
based on advice from a friend,
that I was going to try to become
a technical writer,
because what technical writers do
is actually translate
technical information into something
digestible and understandable
by a layperson.
And so, this is like 1989 timeframe.
And I was applying to the very few
software companies that were around,
and one of them happened to be Adobe.
And so, back in 1989,
I'm having this interview at Adobe
and they're asking me questions like,
"What do you know about
print reproduction and photography?"
And the answer to all of those
questions was, "I know nothing".
But they hired me
to be a technical writer
and my first assignment was to write
the tutorial for Photoshop version 1.0.
No. Really?
Yes. Seriously.
Yes. Yes.
And if you give me a minute,
I'll probably, I have a copy here,
I'm sure. I'll pull it out of my drawer.
Wow, that is so cool.
Can you see that?
Yeah.
Wow.
That was 1989.
It actually came out in 1990.
So, that was my first job in tech.
You wrote a book basically.
That was your first published book.
Exactly.
That is just incredible.
And I wrote several after
for Photoshop and Illustrator
and Premier
and all sorts of Adobe products.
And then,
what happened after that is
because I was young
and it was early days
and there were so much going on
in Silicon Valley, so I moved around
from company to company.
So, I went from Adobe to Symantec.
Actually, that's not the order.
I went from Adobe to EFI to a startup,
Symantec and then finally Autodesk.
So, I basically, in 10 years
from '89 to '99,
I was a technical writer
at five different companies
in the Valley, and then in '99,
I landed at Autodesk.
And I ended up staying at Autodesk
for 20 years.
And I went on this crazy journey, right.
So, talk to me about this crazy journey
because you end up
as vice president at Autodesk,
which is incredible itself.
But it's always the journey
that's even more impressive.
So, talk to me about the different
stepping blocks that you've gone through
during your time at Autodesk.
Well, as I said,
I started as a writer back in '99.
And what happened
pretty soon after I started
is that my manager decided
that she wanted me to be a manager.
She said she needed a manager,
she needed someone to manage the writers,
and she saw potential in me
for leadership and management.
And I hadn't aspired to that at all.
Michael, I was just,
I was happy doing writing.
And yet I said,
"Well, I'll give it a try."
She kind of twisted my arm.
And so, I started being a manager
of other technical writers.
And then it turned out,
I love that, because
I'm very much a people person
and I love the figuring out
how people tick
and that everyone's different
and that you can't manage
10 different people in the same way.
And so, I got into management
and then I did that for several years,
leading the technical writers.
And then I decided I was bored.
And I'd been doing technical writing
for 10 years.
And I've managed writers
for a few more years.
And I'm like, I want to learn
something totally new.
This is kind of how I am when I,
that's why I moved around so much
for those first 10 years.
I just wanted to learn new things.
So, I started looking around
for a new job,
both inside of Autodesk and outside.
And it turned out there was this
really interesting job internally
to lead a team of engineers
who were managing our software
for localization.
So, for those of you who don't know,
localization is actually
getting everything translated
and ready for international markets.
And there's this very specific software
that they were managing
that was really complex
and they needed a new manager
for the team.
So, I applied for that job
and that was for me,
a real stepping stone because,
you know, going from managing writers
where I could do the work
to managing engineers,
where I couldn't do
the work that they did
was a real big jump for me.
And I had to interview
with a zillion people to get that job.
And I got it.
So, that was my first job
out of my comfort zone, really.
That's incredible.
And I have to understand
a little bit better this process
of being a technical writer.
And for example,
taking the Photoshop version 1.0
guide for the layperson,
talk to me a little bit
about that process,
I don't think neither myself
nor most of my friends know really
what goes into writing these guides.
So, how does that process actually look?
Yeah, and you know, it's so interesting.
I mean, even the terminology,
I don't think we even use the term
technical writer anymore.
It's often content designer,
content developer
is much more common now.
And is often seem as part of design
and UX and all of that.
But back in the day,
we called it technical writing.
But what it really is and, you know,
you have all,
you and everyone else,
whoever listens to this
has experienced bad technical writing.
It's when you buy something
and you get the instructions
and you can't follow them
or they're just plain wrong
or they don't make sense.
What good technical writing is,
is that the writer sits down
and truly learns the software
like Inside and out or whatever it is,
hardware, software.
I spent, and my process was
I would learn everything I could
on my own, and I would read
whatever specifications,
I would play with the software.
But then I would sit down
with the engineers,
the developers of the software and say,
explain this to me
so that I completely understood it,
and only then could I write about it.
Because, I mean,
if you've ever tried to explain something
you don't understand,
it doesn't work, right?
But if you understand it, you can take
what is complex and make it simple.
And I think people,
this is one of the things
I really learned,
and as I got better as a writer is,
how can you take something
infinitely complicated
and make it as simple as possible.
And that was always my goal.
Now, you mentioned to me
before this that, you know,
going back to your major,
drama in French, it's kind of played
an interesting role in your career
as it was unfolding
into the different perspectives.
And the skill sets that you had,
while they didn't seem to align
with the positions and what you had to,
would you had to use,
they actually were pretty beneficial.
Tell me a little bit about
how that came about.
Yeah, I thought about that over the years
because it's not necessarily obvious.
But, you know, one thing I think is
whenever you study
and learn a foreign language,
and I lived in France
and I'm really fluent in French,
so I was able to immerse myself
in another language and culture.
I think that makes you just much more
adaptable to different cultures
and different perspectives.
Because you've learned to think
in another language.
I think that really helps in just,
I mean, I've worked in
very international companies
so working with people
from different cultures
whose first language is not English.
And so to me,
it's always about communicating clearly,
trying to understand the other person.
And I think that has really
served me well.
And then from drama, I mean,
drama is one of these
underestimated skills, I think,
because certainly acting
you learn to listen
to the other person.
You learn to improvise
because unexpected things happen.
You learn to communicate in both
verbal and non-verbal ways.
And you learn,
I think the thing that
certainly stage acting and I know,
I never did film,
but I know this is true,
it's such a collaborative process.
You know, the actor
is only as good as the director
and the lighting and the costumes
and everything else.
And what I loved about theater is
the collaborative nature of it,
and I really saw the parallels
in developing software.
Because software
is not just the software developer,
it's the designer,
it's the product manager,
it's the marketing people
and the salespeople and those
technical writers and the QA people.
And all of that
is what makes a great product.
And that's the same in theater.
So, I think all of the skills
are transportable.
I have to look back
to my high school days,
I was a huge musical theater geek.
I still am a musical theater fan,
but I used to take part in every musical
and every play that we had in school.
My dream as a child was to be
an actor on stage
for the rest of my life.
It turned out that I fell in love
with computers and software.
And so, that's where I'm at now.
But looking back,
I see it in every single
aspect of my life.
I see it in my relationships,
I see it in the way
that I communicate with people,
this collaborative nature
of what you're saying
and you've mentioned that
you're only as good
as you are as a group.
And being on stage,
I remember in the shows,
you know, we were kids,
we've made mistakes all the time.
Somebody would forget their lines
in the middle of the play
or this prop would fall from the sky.
And we would find ourselves
in this situation where we realized that,
you know, we can't look good
if we distance ourselves
from the problem.
We have to go at it together.
And if we try to distance ourselves,
we're only doing harm both to ourselves
and to everybody else.
And so, I really, really appreciate
this insight
and I couldn't agree more with it.
Yeah, so it's not obvious
that drama and French
are the perfect preparation
to eventually become VP of engineering
at a software company.
But in my mind,
it couldn't have been better, honestly.
So, if anybody's listening to this
from Stanford and they're studying CS,
consider moving to the drama
or foreign language departments
and you'll get perhaps to the same spot.
But Minette, along the way,
you make this pretty radical transition
from being vice president
at an amazing company like Autodesk
to starting to speak to others
and to share some of the key insights
that you've gained along your career.
Some of it is about compassion,
about empathy, about acceptance.
So, what are some of those insights?
Well, I think I have to backtrack
a little bit
to tell you how I got to that.
So, we sort of stopped with my career
that I got to manage some engineers.
And then many years went by
and I ended up taking on
a series of other leadership positions
in the company.
But to get to that VP of engineering job,
I had gotten to a senior director role,
I led a big department in the company,
but to get to that VP role,
I had to basically,
the guy who was hiring
for that role said,
"You know Minette,
you've got a great track record here,
I know you're a good leader,
but you have two strikes against you."
And he was very clear
about those two strikes.
He said,
"One, you were never an engineer.
So, you have to gain credibility
with the engineering community
because although you've been in tech
and you are technical,
you weren't the one developing software.
So you've got to gain credibility."
And two, he said,
"You're a woman.
And the engineering leadership here
is a boys club.
And so, you're going to have
to break into the boys club."
And so what happened is
I did not get the job right away.
I had to do a 90 day trial.
And during those 90 day,
yeah, I did an acting role.
So, I was acting VP for three months.
And yeah,
and during those three months,
I basically had to win the endorsements
of all the engineering leaders
in the company.
And they happened, at that time,
to be all men.
Wow.
So, you were acting VP for three months.
You have to get the acceptance
of that boys club.
Okay. That's incredible.
Go on.
So, I did.
I mean, it's a long story,
but I eventually,
I did get that role
and I did that role
for about five years.
And during the time,
and my goal,
what I was basically assigned to do
was to transform engineering at Autodesk,
which is, you can imagine, a huge task.
It was about 9,000 people
when I was there,
about 3,500 engineers.
And I realized none of this
is a technical problem.
I mean we had a lot of issues,
we had all these different platforms
and we had to really consolidate tools.
But it was a behavioral issue,
it was a people issue
and it was culture.
It was all about culture
and how we behaved.
And I got, as in that role is like,
yeah, I had a great staff,
I had very technical people
working under me,
but what I needed to do
was really talk about
how are we going to behave differently,
how are we going to collaborate,
how are we going to work
more effectively together.
And so I got myself a
big education really
through reading and being online
and just reading a zillion books
about human behavior.
And I also became a real advocate
for women and for people of color,
because even though I am a white woman,
I was very much in the minority
because engineering is so male.
And so, I often felt other,
I often felt like I didn't fit in,
like I wasn't included.
And I wanted to change that.
And so, when I finally left Autodesk
after 20 years, I left last year,
I realized, you know,
Autodesk is a great company,
but they're struggling with this,
all the companies
are struggling with inclusion.
Diversity, inclusion and equity.
And so, I wanted to bring my perspective
and my experience
and help others do better around this.
Because, honestly,
everyone's struggling
and everyone needs help with that.
Minette, you're vice president
in the engineering space.
3,500 engineers at Autodesk
and you're coming, you're saying,
talking about how this is
a behavioral problem,
its culture at the end.
And of course, you know, in 2020,
we've seen that not just in tech,
but around the world
of how big of a part
culture plays into our life
and into our ability to thrive
just as a planet,
and as a global community.
And I'd love for you to share
a little bit more into the insights
of how do you build a healthy culture
both in large, large corporation
like Autodesk,
but also in a small startup?
And I'm looking specifically
selfish insights for me
as I'm about to start
my own entrepreneurial journey
and for all of my friends
that are in their journey,
what are some key insights
that you've gained about behavior
and about culture
and diversity and inclusion?
Yeah.
Well, there's so much
and it is kind of hard to know
where to start.
But what I will say is that
the leaders really set the tone.
And I think, especially,
big companies and small,
but when you're a startup,
often, and I've seen this,
so much startups are going really fast.
We're going to build
something really cool,
we're going to get it out there,
we're going to try to get investment,
we're going to try to get customers,
and then later even, you know,
even with a startup, they'll say,
Oh, look, we're all men.
Now, we got to hire some women
and how are we going to do that?
And it's almost too late,
even if you're just a handful of men,
because, do the women
want to come work there,
do the people of color
want to come work there.
So, I think that whether
you're large or small,
starting up or a 30 year old company,
you need to be intentional
and the leaders need to set the tone
of being inclusive,
and what that means
in terms of leadership,
and this is a lot
of the work that I do is that
leaders are not omniscient
and they need to admit
what they don't know.
They need to be vulnerable.
They need to be open to listening.
And honestly, that is so much of what
I think the problem is right now
is that people don't know how to listen
to their diverse employees
and to hear their true experiences.
And I've experienced this myself.
A senior executive will say,
"Don't bring me problems,
bring me solutions."
But honestly,
you need to hear the problems
before you can even attempt
the solutions.
And you need to be uncomfortable
with that listening.
You need to be willing
to be uncomfortable and to say,
I don't have all the answers,
but I'm willing to listen
and I'm going to make sure
that this is a safe place
where everyone's voice can be heard.
And to me, that is
the number one thing is that
we have to make it safe.
And people do not feel safe today
speaking up and telling their truth.
Right.
And I love your take on
being intentional about as a leader
and being vocal about it,
and being willing to be uncomfortable
with the problem.
And not just sugarcoating it
or shrugging it aside.
I think it's wonderful.
How do you then make the impact now?
So, you've left Autodesk.
Part of the motivation
from what I'm hearing from you is
understand that you've made
an incredible impact
at your company, Autodesk.
Then, this is a global problem
along with many companies,
and you're now looking
to make that impact there.
So, how do you go about doing that?
Yeah.
Well, I started my own
consulting business
this summer during covid
because what else do you do
during covid, right?
I took a break and then realized
that's what I wanted to do.
But I've also, for many years,
even when I was at Autodesk,
I was a keynote speaker
internally and externally.
So I've been doing recently
a fair number of keynotes
that there's a real appetite
to hear about diversity and inclusion.
And so, I had one last month,
I have one this next Friday.
So, I'm trying to get the word out.
But I do have a new client
and that's a start up,
and they're realizing
that they may have an issue
with equity and with inclusion.
And so, we're just starting
the conversations.
And so, I'm doing both
just the one on one engagements
with smaller, large companies,
and that's just starting.
And then, I'm also giving talks
because I feel like people
just need to hear.
And one of the things is that
I will be honest in those talks.
I'm not going to sugarcoat things
and say that it's all perfect
and I'll share
my own experiences as well.
I love that.
Minette, I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
Before we go, I have to ask
the most important question.
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
All right.
I have to start with authentic,
because you only get one Minette.
I don't have different personas
for different environments.
It's I'm always going to be real.
So, authentic.
Empathetic.
I can't even turn off my empathy.
And that's both a blessing and a curse.
So, if you start crying, it's likely
that I'm going to be crying with you.
But, you know,
that's just who I am.
And then the third is,
I don't know if I would say
energetic or enthusiastic,
I'll go with enthusiastic.
Because I've just got a lot of,
I've got so much oomph
and I have so much I want to share
and I want to help people
and I want to get at it.
Wonderful.
Minette, thank you so much.
This is wonderful.
Continue making a positive impact
in helping companies
regain the equity and diverse nature
that they all deserve and we all deserve.
And I look forward to seeking your advice
when I'm starting my own venture
to make sure that I properly
I'm leading by example
and being intentional about it.
So, thank you.
Thank you.
I would love to continue that with you.
Michael, thanks so much.
Take care.